[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICOLE KRAMER: Hi.
My name is Nicole
Kramer, and I'm
a third-year bioinformatics and
computational biology graduate
student at the University of
North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
Today, I'm really
honored to be talking
to you about a new
paradigm for multi figure
coordinate-based
plotting in R that I've
begun to make possible
with my package BentoBox
The inspiration for this
package and this functionality
within the R
plotting environment
came from some of my own
stressful experiences
as a grad student making
figures and plots.
There was one time
when my advisor asked
me to make a multi-paneled
figure that looked something
like this.
There were two heatmap style plots
in a specific genomic region.
There were two tracks
of genes below that.
There were six different tracks
of bin signal data below those.
And there was a bar graph
of some statistical analysis
done in R.
And since I work in genomics,
all of this data was huge.
One heatmap came from a
file that was 55 gigabytes.
And the other came from a
file that was 14 gigabytes.
One set of those bin data came
from three different files that
totaled 1.2 gigabytes,
and the other
came from three other files
that totaled 1.7 gigabytes.
And on top of this
data being huge,
the process to make
this combined figure
was extremely tedious
and time-consuming,
with all of its elements
coming from different places.
There were different
screenshots of a couple
of genomic browsers.
There was a plot made
from data analyzed
in R. Everything was cropped and
arranged in Adobe Illustrator,
and all of the fine
tuning and nice labels
were also made in
Adobe Illustrator.
So when my advisor asked me to
change the genomic coordinates
I was looking at in this
figure, it wasn't a simple fix.
And I went to my
overcrowded laptop screen
with a bunch of genomic browsers
open, with my Dropbox open,
with all the files I was working
at my RStudio window, my Adobe
Illustrator window,
and the paper
I was taking inspiration from.
And I became
completely overwhelmed.
I thought that there
had to be an easier way
to make figures like this
beyond existing browsers,
beyond existing
programmatic libraries,
and things that I didn't
need to use graphic design
software for that would
let me make and arrange
all my plots in one place.
Something that was entirely
reproducible by being
completely programmatic,
yet entirely
customizable and efficient
for handling large data
specifically.
And so my team and I developed
a package called BentoBox that
allows for coordinate-based
plotting in R
where plots can be
programmatically made
and arranged on a
user-defined page layout
with common units
of measurement.
Here is an example I'm showing
you two tiny page markings
with inches and centimeters.
So let's talk about
how Bento Box makes
figures entirely programmatic.
If we go back to that figure I
made by combining screenshots
in Adobe Illustrator, I can
now make a precisely tailored
version of that figure entirely
in R. The code on the left
is every command needed to
make the figure on the right.
I've squished it
down for you here,
and it's not important that you
look at the code I've written.
But just know that if I gave you
this file and the data files,
you could make the
exact same figure
that I've made on the right.
So here I can give my
advisor the file, the data,
and they can make that
figure just as they want it.
I can define all my files
and data and just one place.
And here, with one
line of code, I
can easily change
the coordinates
that I'm looking at while
keeping the rest of the figure
structure and
aesthetics the same.
So if my advisor wants
to change the region,
but have everything
else look the same,
I now only have to do that
with one line of code.
BentoBox also makes plots
entirely customizable,
just as you could
for other plots
in R. I now have the
power to really customize
a bunch of things
about my plots.
I can really easily change their
color palettes, font sizes,
font types, dimensions,
et cetera, et cetera.
So let's say my advisor didn't
like those heat maps being red,
and he wanted those bin signal
tracks to be slightly taller.
We can now easily make
both of our heat maps
with a blue color
palette and quickly
adjust the dimensions
of all those tracks, all
while maintaining
picture clarity
and not having to
squish any of our data.
One of the really special
customizations in BentoBox
is its ability to perform
coordinate-based plotting
on a page with precise
placements and dimensions.
So here we can
define a BentoBox
page that is exactly 9 inches
wide and 5 inches tall.
And now we can make and
arrange all of our plots
within this defined landscape.
So if we want the
top corner of a plot
to be 2 inches down from the
top of the page and 1 inch
from the left, and we want the
plot to be 3 inches wide and 1
inch tall, we can exactly make
our plot with these parameters.
And it'll fit right in
that box we defined.
This exact sizing
and placement is
particularly
important and useful
for standardized and
accurate data comparisons.
So this both applies
along the y-axis,
if we're looking at
two plots side-by-side
and they have the
same scale, we want
to make sure we're comparing
that data correctly.
And it's also important
for comparing data
along the same
coordinates of the x-axis.
So here in the case
of genomics, we're
looking at a specific
region along the genome.
And we want to compare
the data that's
specifically in that region.
And while there are other
tools, like patchwork and
cowplot for arranging
plots in R, none
are as precise and
specifically tailored
for a multi-plot
environment like BentoBox.
So here I've made
two example ggplots
using the mtcars dataset.
And I'm going to show you
how they work differently
in patchwork, cowplot,
and BentoBox.
Patchwork is specialized
for the easy arrangement
of plots and grids.
So here we can just
define plot 1 plus plot 2,
and patchwork will place
them side-by-side for us.
And cowplot expands
on these grid layouts
and gives you
slight more control
of the relative dimensions
and plot placements.
So here I can define
that I want the left plot
to be slightly smaller
and shifted to the left
to the right--
of the plot on the right.
But these options both have
issues of placement and size
accuracy, which can become
a problem, both in terms
of aesthetics and
data interpretation.
So as you can see here, the
relative placements and sizes
of the plots mean
that they can easily
get squished or
stretched, especially when
we're moving around our
graphic device window,
or if we're exporting
it in different sizes.
This does not happen
with BentoBox plots,
because everything
is aligned and spaced
exactly how we want it to be.
So, here, if we're
placing those same plots
on a page that is defined
to be 8 inches wide and 4
inches tall, we can see as
we move the R graphic device
window around, it adjusts to
maintain those dimensions.
And despite plotting
and customizing
extremely large datasets,
BentoBox functions
are extremely
efficient, because they
were optimized to be able to
quickly plot large datasets.
So if we go back to
our previous figure
that we made with
BentoBox, we can
see how quick it
is to generate each
of the main elements
of our plot.
So our two heat maps here
took only 0.6 seconds to plot.
Our genomic labeling
and our gene tracks
took 0.06 seconds to plot.
Each of our signal tracks took
less than 1 second to plot.
And adding our ggplot
took 0.4 seconds.
In the end, it only took
my laptop about 3 seconds
to generate this whole figure
coming from many large data
files.
And if our advisor wants
us to visually scan
through our large
datasets, we can now
programmatically
and easily make them
aesthetic informative
figures in bulk.
So here I've made 20 files
of the same style of figure,
but looking through
different regions of a file.
And they're all plotted in
the exact way I want them,
and I can easily scan
through all of this data.
So now that we've gone
through some of BentoBox's
key features, I want to take you
through a walkthrough of a plot
that we made with
some genomic data.
So, first, we can initialize
our BentoBox page
with the exact dimensions
in our unit of choice.
As an American, I have
chosen inches here.
This function will by
default add ticks and guides
to add you in your
figure-building process
to make sure you're placing
things and arranging them
in the way you want.
So, first, here we can
add 1/2 of a heat map
from a file and its associated
color scale at one corner.
We can add the bottom
half of this heat map
from a different file
in a different color
palette with its
associated color scale.
We can replace those two heat
maps with one square heat
map that's exactly 3 inches
wide and 3 inches tall
and easily change
its color palette.
We can mark up the dark
pixels on that heat map
that in the genomic field
we denote as DNA loops.
And we can do this with
a variety of options.
So here we can do this with
circles, or with arrows,
or with squares.
And in this case, we can just
highlight one specific loop
region and annotate
that with text,
if that's what we
want to look at.
We can next line up and add
a different representation
for these loop regions
as two boxes connected
by line segments.
And this track is exactly the
same width as our heat map
and in the height
that we want it to be.
Or we can change this data
into a different representation
by marking them up
as connected arches.
Below this, and
lined up to our heatmap
and these arch
representations,
we can now add
different bin signal
tracks from different files
and in different colors.
For each of these, we can change
the y ranges and the heights
of all these different plots.
We can then line up
the track of genes
that fall in this exact region
of data that we're looking at.
So we can show both
strands of the DNA,
show the structure of the
genes, and label them.
We can easily change the colors
of every element of this gene
track and make it all gray
or all a different color.
Or we can just highlight
a specific gene
in a color of our choosing.
And finally below this
entire collection of data,
we can label the x-axis
of genomic coordinates
that we're looking at and
really line it up to everything
we've built up so far.
But beyond looking
at these lined up
tracks of different data
that you might already
see in a genomic browser, we can
also add various plot elements
to our page in different
locations, sizes,
and orientations really
with no limitations.
So, first, on this
right side we can now
add a picture representation of
a chromosome and the specified
width.
Below that, we can zoom in and
highlight a specific region
of the chromosome and
add two different heat
maps of the same size and
region right next to each other
to compare those two
different data types.
We can change those square
heatmaps into triangle ones,
if that suits our fancy.
We can add two more bin signal
tracks below our other heatmaps,
this time making them the
same width as our smaller heatmap
since we're
comparing along that axis.
We can zoom in on a specific
region of that bin data
to compare a specific
peak of data.
And we can also add the
sequencing read pile-ups that
represent that bin signal data.
And we can change the color for
each of the two strands of DNA.
And, finally, again, we can add
our label genomic coordinates
below each of these
zoomed regions of data.
And when we're done building
up and tweaking our plot
to our liking, we can remove all
of those guides from our page
and export our
publication quality figure
in the size we made
it at the beginning.
So we can use it
in research papers,
or presentations
just like this one.
So this entire plot is exactly
what I built up in BentoBox.
And so if we compare
BentoBox to existing
programmatic
libraries, we can see
that both are programmatic
and reproducible.
Both are fully customizable.
And both integrate a wide
variety of data types.
However, BentoBox is
specialized to handle
large datasets
like genomic data.
And only Bento Box gives
users the precise control
of plot placements
and dimensions.
BentoBox
currently has
functions for genomic data,
but I hope its paradigms will
extend our plotting environment
for all kinds of
data visualizations.
If you're interested
in trying out BentoBox
and exploring how you can
use it with your data,
you can get BentoBox
from my lab's GitHub page,
or feel free to
tweet at me directly.
Thank you so much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]